et la 17e attaque en un mois Bruno Darou
il y a une intensification des attaques
dans le ciel
ukrainien est donc maintenant le ciel
russe oui alors évidemment c'est
toujours très compliqué Julien
d'affirmer des choses puisqu'on est
clairement dans une guerre
informationnelle entre Kiev et Moscou
alors Moscou assume elle de lancer des
missiles et des drones notamment en ce
moment très souvent sur Kiev avec donc
un double objectif qui est psychologique
et sans doute aussi un peu militaire
puisque l'un des aéroports de autour de
la capitale a été a été touchée mais
évidemment côté ukrainien c'est pas la
même chose
puisque
en ce qui concerne ces 8 drones qui se
sont abattus au sud-ouest de Moscou
Kief des mots toute implication et
constate simplement que il y a des
attaques qui se répètent bon il y avait
évidemment dans la région de Belgorod
donc bon le plus plausible le plus
logique c'est que le tir de du drone
soit une forme de riposte de la part de
Kiev face à ses nombreux attaques vous
l'avez dit effectivement 17 attaques
russes contre la capitale au mois de mai
après on aura jamais de certitudes de
toute façon l'Ukraine ne peut pas
reconnaître officiellement qu'à
l'attaque le territoire russe d'abord
parce que évidemment ça ferait monter
l'attention sérieusement et d'autre part
mais c'est lié les alliés occidentaux de
l'Ukraine ont clairement fait comprendre
à Kiev qu'il n'était pas question que
l'Ukraine s'en prenne au territoire
russe donc on est dans cette espèce de
je sais pas comment dire de jeux de
poker menteur où il y a des choses qui
se passent mais l'Ukraine dit ah oui
tiens je constate que bon le plus
plausible c'est que c'est ou alors ce
sont des groupes alors voilà ce sont des
groupes pro Ukraine y compris des
groupes russes pro-uraient assez drôle
mais il s'agit à l'évidence d'une façon
pour Kiev de marquer le coup contre
Moscou alors par contre en territoire
ukrainien il une il y a une attaque avec
des
Storm Shadows donc les missiles
britanniques très sophistiqués vient
d'acquérir il y a un de ces missiles qui
a été tiré contre un hôpital tout près
de Mario Paul à la fameuse ville qui est
tombée entre les mains des Russes au
printemps dernier et cet hôpital a été
transformé en base militaire russe et
apparemment il y aurait eu beaucoup de
victimes tués et blessés parmi les
militaires russes et tout cela s'inscrit
dans le cadre de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne que l'on attend depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois même oui alors en fait vu ce qui se
passe depuis maintenant plusieurs jours
presque plusieurs semaines même mais là
il y a eu une accélération depuis une
quinzaine de jours soit on est dans les
prémices de la contre-offensive de part
et d'autre c'est-à-dire qu'on cherche à
viser des cibles qui vont affaiblir
l'ennemi dans le cadre de sa
contre-fensive soit on est carrément
dans une première phase de contrefensive
ce qu'on appelle le shape le modelage
qui cherche donc justement à affaiblir
les capacités de l'ennemi
potentiellement aussi à briser le moral
des populations et donc on verra
peut-être que dans un ou deux mois on
dira que c'était le début de la de la
contrefaie pour le moment on va se
contenter de parler de près de prémices
de modelage ce qui fait sans doute dire
que la contre-offensive
ukrainienne devrait avoir lieu dans peu
de temps de toute façon vu la période de
l'année à laquelle nous arrivons le mois
de juin qui est propice à ce genre de de
contre-offensive après les militaires
déterminent à une fourchette de dattes
et puis quand il voit que le jour J et
le bon en termes notamment de climat
c'est très important et bien à ce
moment-là il déclenche il déclenche
cette contrefensive merci pour ces
éléments brun